SMEAR, FORMER
GOVERNOR MIKE HUCKABEE AND
FORMER FBI SENIOR OFFICIAL
CHRIS SWECKER REACT.
BUT FIRST OVER THE PAST FEW
NIGHTS, WE HAVE BEEN LAYING OUT
THE COORDINATED EFFORT BY A
CABAL OF DIPLOMATIC AND INTEL
BUREAUCRATS TO OFFEND THE
PRESIDENCY OF DONALD TRUMP.
WHEN THE PRESIDENT CALLED THEM
OUT FOR THEIR CATASTROPHIC
FAILURES OF PROCESS AND POLICY,
THEY WERE OFFENDED.
WHEN HE DEMANDED THAT NATO
COUNTRIES.
FREE WRITING ON THE U.S.
TAXPAYERS, THEY WERE HORRIFIED.
WHEN HE BEGAN MAKING GOOD ON HIS
PROMISE TO BRING HOME OUR
TROOPS, THEY WERE SHOCKED.
WHEN THE DEEP STATES INSURANCE
POLICY AND RUSSIA COLLUSION
NARRATIVE IMPLODED, THEY DECIDED
TO BRING IN REINFORCEMENTS.
OF COURSE, THEY FOUND THEM IN
THE HOUSE.
DEMOCRATS ARE SERIOUSLY TRYING
TO CONSTRUCT AN ABUSE OF POWER
ARTICLE OF IMPEACHMENT.
I HAVE A QUESTION, IF TRUMP IS
SO OBVIOUSLY OFF THE RAILS, WHY
NOT HOLD THEIR FAKE IMPEACHMENT
INQUIRY OUT IN THE OPEN?
SUNLIGHT IS THE BEST POLITICAL
DISINFECTANT.
EASY ANSWER.
THE CLOSED-DOOR SHUFFLE ALLOWS
DEMOCRATS TO PRESET THE THEME OF
EACH WITNESS, SPIN THE SECRET
TESTIMONY, CHERRY PICK THEN LEAK
THE PHRASE IS MOST FAVORABLE TO
THEIR IMPEACHMENT NARRATIVE.
ACTING AMBASSADOR TO UKRAINE TO
BILL TAYLOR, A NEVER TRUMPER
HIMSELF, HAD HIS TURN IN THE
STAR CHAMBER TODAY.
>> IT'S NOT EVEN NOON AND THIS
IS THE MOST DISTURBING DAY IN
CONGRESS SO FAR.
IT'S VERY TROUBLING.
>> THE TESTIMONY WAS EXPLOSIVE,
I WOULD SAY THIS IS THE TOP
WITNESS WE HAVE LEARNED FROM SO
FAR.
>> HE GAVE TREMENDOUS TESTIMONY
TODAY.
>> Laura: SPIN SPIN SPIN.
SOURCES FAMILIAR WITH THE
TESTIMONY TOLD FOX NEWS THAT
TAYLOR DIDN'T OFFER ANY NEW
EVIDENCE AND HAVE ZERO
FIRST-HAND KNOWLEDGE OR DIRECT
EVIDENCE OF THE QUID PRO QUO
THAT DEMOCRATS CLAIM WAS A
SLAM-DUNK.
THIS ISN'T ABOUT THE TRUTH.
THIS IS ABOUT CONFIRMING A
THESIS REGARDLESS OF THE FACT
THAT THE UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT
SAID THERE WAS NO PRESSURE
APPLIED TO HIM AND NO QUID PRO
QUO.
WHICH BRINGS US TO THE MEDIA.
THEY HAVE BEEN ACHING FOR
IMPEACHMENT SINCE ELECTION NIGHT
AND THUS WILL PARROT WHATEVER
ADAM SCHIFF SPITS OUT, NO
QUESTIONS ASKED.
>> IT IS ENTIRELY POSSIBLE THIS
DAY WILL TURN OUT TO BE ONE OF
THE MOST CONSEQUENTIAL DAYS IN
THE IMPEACHMENT INQUIRY.
>> THE IMPEACHMENT MAY HAVE BEEN
TURBOCHARGED BUT HIS TESTIMONY
OF CAREER DIPLOMAT BILL TAYLOR.
>> BILL TAYLOR WAS NOT JUST A
SMOKING GUN, THIS WAS A SMOKING
HOWITZER.
>> Laura: IT GETS BETTER.
THEY DON'T JUST PUBLISH ARTICLES
WITH COMPLETELY ANONYMOUS
SOURCES.
LAST YEAR, "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
PUBLISHED AN ENTIRE OP-ED
WRITTEN BY AN ANONYMOUS
SUPPOSEDLY SENIOR TRUMP OFFICIAL
WHO EVEN CLAIMED TO BE HIMSELF
PART OF THE RESISTANCE,
PATRIOTIC RESISTANCE.
MR. COURAGEOUS ALSO SHOP A BOOK
DEAL, AT DROPS NEXT MONTH.
ACCORDING TO THE PUBLISHER, THE
AUTHOR SEES THIS AS AN ACT OF
CONSCIENCE AND OF DUTY, WHAT A
CROCK.
EVERY ANTI-TRUMP TABLER IS
DEPICTED AS A SELFLESS SAINT IN
THE MEDIA.
IT ALL SMACKS OF DESPERATION TO
ME.
THE LEFT'S HATRED FOR THIS
PRESIDENT HAS BEEN WELL
DOCUMENTED BUT WHAT THEY ARE NOW
OPENLY SIGNALING IS THEY DON'T
LIKE YOU, THE AMERICAN VOTER,
EITHER.
THEY DON'T TRUST YOU TO DELIVER
A RESULT THAT THEY WANT SO THEY
WILL TRY TO REMOVE THIS ENTIRE
PROCESS FROM YOUR HANDS
ALTOGETHER.
THE PRESIDENT WON ELECTION
NEARLY THREE YEARS AGO AS AN
OUTSIDER AND I WAS THINKING
ABOUT THIS -- I THINK TODAY,
IRONICALLY, HE'S STILL KIND OF
AN OUTSIDER.
WHAT DO I MEAN?
THE BIPARTISAN ESTABLISHMENT,
THEY NEVER ACCEPTED HIM AS
LEGITIMATE.
THIS DESPITE HIS STELLAR
ECONOMIC RECORD, RECORD NUMBER
OF JUDGES CONFIRMED, AND THE
LEADERSHIP HE HAS SHOWN AGAINST
THE CHINA THREAT.
HE'S STILL A DISRUPTER, HE'S
STILL THE ULTIMATE RORSCHACH
TEST FOR THE OLD GUARD.
THE BETTER AMERICA DOES UNDER
TRUMP, THE MORE NEGATIVELY THEY
THINK THAT REFLECTS ON THE
SO-CALLED EXPERTS WHO FOR
DECADES IT SQUANDERED AMERICAN
PROSPERITY FOR GLOBAL INSANITY.
IF THEY CAN IMPEACH TRUMP EVEN
ON A BOGUS NARRATIVE TEASED OUT
IN SECRET, THE PERMANENT
RESISTANCE CAN SAY "SEE, I TOLD
YOU SO" AND FEEL VINDICATED --
THIS IS THEIR REVENGE.
YET AS USUAL THEY UNDERESTIMATE
THE COMMON SENSE OF THE AMERICAN